what did you make last month between 8
and 10K from one pound Crush course to
where we are now in just a year it's
incredible and now you don't need to
worry about any other work we became
financially free with the first property
if you're trying to invest a hundred
grand with no mentoring no knowledge no
support you might be successful but
trying to invest 90 grand but with
unlimited mentoring all the support it's
going to go way further it really has
changed our lives
so Gavin and Anna thanks so much firstly
for coming down to my house on winners
on a Wednesday thank you for inviting us
and you guys are what we call like
accidental property investors I know now
you're very deliberate but initially you
made your first chunk of money through
property which was kind of on accident
by chance talk to you about how you got
into property and and why well yeah I
guess it was by accident because we
didn't actually know what we were really
doing we obviously we're married and
we've got two children so when we got
married we bought our first property in
Hertfordshire so I'm from London but we
moved out to Hertfordshire
and it was a rundown too bad wasn't it
yeah we run down the hex Council house
run down too
and there is no pictures of yeah and you
lived in it we did we lived there for
five years it was it was the cheapest
two bed in the whole of the town where
we live we we done it up
when we booked a dead viewing we
actually bought my mother-in-law to give
us approval oh yeah yeah and she
actually secretly did not approve no no
no she didn't like it she said but
because we're so excited and we walked
in and we saw the potential yeah what
can done into yeah so we're just like
how old do you think we can walk and she
was like yes yes but after that's it
yeah after six I mean if you can buy the
the worst houses on the best streets
um then you're gonna have money yeah
exactly and to be fair we lived there
for about five years obviously and we
obviously had our children so they grew
up there in early years and when we sold
we actually made 60 Grand yeah you know
we actually made 60 Grand profit so we
sold it for 200 we bought for 140 so we
was actually laughing and that opened
our eyes a little bit didn't it and that
helped us to buy the house we're living
in Hell we've been been in our new house
for about five years and we've done um a
kitchen extension and Loft conversion
and stuff like that about five years ago
which was the same situation we didn't
have much money to put it down to buy
the SEC on the property because it came
from the flatty into a house the area
where he lives it's a very expensive
area so we didn't have much money so we
again we went to the same me strategy
without knowing we will do it so we both
have very run down property in a very
nice Road in a very nice area and we
repeat the process so we went there with
the next station we done the Loft
converted and we just pushed the value
up without the realizing what we're
doing and then when you sell it you
don't pay tax because it's your main
residence you make a chunk of money and
then you can upgrade your house and
slowly slowly slowly so exactly then we
refinance the property and we just took
a big chunk of money from the from the
property and we just put in the bank
waiting to be reinvested right yeah yeah
now I know right now you're actually
doing a lot in property which we're
going to get to are you worried about
the market and where it's at and do you
decent arms think oh man maybe we maybe
we've already enjoyed the Heyday and
maybe the days of property investing are
kind of over now to be honest no no two
no not two no not at all of anything we
are glad we came in that particular
moment yeah we're excited for the future
and if anything I'd say it's a buyer's
market right now to be fair yeah you
know there's some deals out there that
you can really hunt around and find some
fantastic deals at the moment we're
actually
doing a strategy of uh we've done um the
renter essays isn't it that's what we've
been doing over the last six months
which has worked fantastic for us that's
that's what we've been doing and now
we're going to move on to bigger and
better things in the future so yeah well
well it's exciting what you're doing and
you've Diversified quite well you've
also got um something going on in
Scotland yeah yeah talk to me about that
I know that's early stages yeah that is
like extremely exciting so tell me a
little bit about that yeah we're excited
about it we're very excited about that
um basically I've um I've got a friend
who lives in Scotland I'm the only my
whole life since moves in Nursery I mean
it's like a brother to me before we knew
about you and before we was in this
property world and we had any knowledge
or anything at all
he kept on approaching us about stuff
he's doing in Scotland you know finding
the right people um he wants to do
affordable housing for the council and
that so he's been up there for a couple
years doing his homework like really
doing his homework when he first
approached us and asked us would we like
to get involved and invest in you know
in in the projects and stuff that's
going on
we we was working in care so we wasn't
really in the property one so to speak
so to us what he was saying didn't
actually mean anything it was just it
meant nothing to us just jogging he was
just talking it didn't really mean
anything and if anything what I was
hearing was do you want to invest and
give some money and basically we were
caring for us it's like okay so do you
want the money I was saving 60 Dollar
Bank to go and put in something we don't
have a clue what do you do it yeah so
the answer is no we we were carers
that's what we were we were working in
care I worked in care for over 20 years
and that's what we were doing so to talk
about Scotland's investment and
developing and councils and affordable
it meant nothing to me yeah absolutely
nothing so basically I wished him good
luck and we kind of left it there
obviously fast forward to over a year
later and now we obviously we join the
academy and we've learned from you and
we're in the right environment
when he come back to me again at the
beginning of the summer
it was a whole it was something
it was a difficult conversation
I actually knew what he was talking
about I mean I'm not an expert yeah but
you know we're learning that's what we
want to do want to keep on learning but
the things he was saying to me that he
said last time were making sense yeah I
could see the vision I could see you
know where this could go I could see the
potential we we was more excited than
the first conversation it was just like
a whole Oasis yeah what is it it's
developing affordable housing for the
council in Scotland so it's 20 developed
a house for the council and we see GDP
of 0.4.6 million million so and it's
going to be be helping to the
opportunity okay but especially
affordable houses exactly that's the big
problem that we've got at the moment
we've got a shortage of houses so that's
exciting and this this is one of the
things that we're really excited about
because it's developing four full house
for the council there's a need yeah so
that's that's good for us because
there's a need and that's good like you
said 40 UK because
people need properties you know if
you're an account it's I grew up in a
council house so I I know how that is my
mum got a counselors for me and my
sisters and brothers and that and it's a
good thing it's a good thing to get
Council house so to now be
developing Council houses for people
it's just it's just amazing well I think
the best way to help the homeless
problem is to build more houses yeah
because they can't afford to rent
because there's not enough houses
therefore the rent is really high yeah
and obviously you'll get paid Hudson
before I would imagine as well yeah I
mean that's that's the best bonus yeah
which which helps so right now then with
your property business you mentioned
you've got rent to rent you've obviously
done your flips you've got your options
you've got your all your development
stuff that you're working on what did
you make last month what did your
property business turnover what was the
profit between eight and 10K 18K profit
profit okay was about 18 18 yeah don't
over and for us
that's just amazing that that's just
yeah we we can't even put into what can
we do I mean that's just the most
interesting
to where we are now in just a year just
over a year yeah it's incredible it's
something fantastic yeah we're we're so
excited how's life changed from a year
ago when you were well yeah when we
joined the Academy I was still working
new animals doing the office side of it
and it was like a family business and my
mom was involved and me and I was doing
I was like the deputy manager my mum was
a manager so I was dealing with the
staff and you know the clients and
service users and stuff like that so we
wanted to close it down after covid
because it got very difficult being on
the front line dealing with families and
people in covet it was very very
difficult to deal with
um and we decided shortly after that we
want to close the company down and we
want to move on to something else but we
didn't really know what to move on
because the business wasn't fantastic
but it was paying me a wage now we will
survive him looking back now that sounds
awful but at the time it was comfortable
I was paying my mortgage my wife and
kids were being supported for for me to
be a man that was what I was raised to
do Looking Back Now
that was just to be honest I was scared
and I was comfortable and I didn't want
to rock the boat so we decided to close
the business down but we didn't know
what we wanted to do my mum was
sorbing's property she's a landlord
she's always had property she's always
told us buy houses buy houses didn't
really listen
um and then what happened was you and my
mum found out about Samuel didn't you
you wanted a one pound course
then from there we'd say okay we what we
want to do is we are so I bought the BR
cools and I went to the VR course then
when I was in the BR you was teaching
about the fast pound and the slow path
right then I realized what we just about
to do it was the wrong strategic because
if we close our business which is the
cash flow how we're going to survive
till we get to the fast but I need it
both
yeah we need both yeah so from there I
thought okay we can't do bi straight
away we have to get somehow the fat cash
flow if we're gonna close our monthly
business yeah we need the replaces a
monthly yeah yeah because you can't rely
on development yeah
I need to understand I need to to know
how to do it so from there I signed for
the Academy but it wasn't that easy
because I sat now if you craze by then
and I called Gavin and I said Gavin just
come down bring some cards uh I'm gonna
sign the for something co-academy and
come and be read because we're also
gonna go for a dinner then that was
three o'clock on okay could I say my
version do I say what happened to me
Alouette on the course to do with
property fantastic I'm still working to
care I'm looking after the kids I'm
doing the school one because Anna's away
again this phone call just as I'm about
to pick up the kids drive down to
Heathrow from art for Sean to the hotel
where the course is being held
bring the cards
it's probably going to be about 100 200
people there now I'm sweating Daniel and
I'm saying hang on what what should I
don't know I can't explain now trust me
I've said Anna Anna she goes trust me
trust me
so I'm like what is my wife doing what
was that hypnotized Yeah so basically I
think I've asked my mum it was my mum or
sister can you look after the kids I
chucked a shirt and I jumped in the car
and I drove I've got out of the car in
the car park and I can see loads of
people hundreds of people standing
around talking everyone's excited
they've all got these badges on gold
badges black badges grow bed I didn't
know what was happening so I found the
Anna she said that to some guy who now I
know is Chris
they're both smile and happy Chris is
saying trust your wife she's a very
clever woman she knows what she's doing
and it's gonna baby trust me I'm looking
at her I'm trying to like make eye
contact with her she goes give me the
cards so what I done was I was typically
British and I thought to myself I'm
going to give you these cards I'm going
to keep my mouth closed we're going to
have a word in the car all the way home
I'm gonna have a world would be on the
way home so basically I trusted my wife
and to be honest over a year later just
over a year later it was the best thing
we ever done it really has changed our
lives so yeah
then from there we so obviously we
joined the academy and I booked myself
with straight to do the selfish
accommodation hmobile boots Camp yeah I
went to there learn about service
accommendation that's because finish it
on Friday then on Saturday we went to
help with my mother-in-law to clean one
of her properties to length out she had
these stay Agents come and give her the
value of the monthly rent and on
Saturday we were like cleaning the house
and Tiding up it getting ready for the
new tenants then I approached her and I
say um what's about Ife you rent the
house for Gavin and I then and I was
thinking fantastic my first rented to
rent this house accommodation perfect
then that is my side of the story
because I've got my outside as well I
think I was holding the broom or
something in the garden doing some
sweeping getting the garden ready and I
just hear my wife say it's my mom we
take on the property we'll pay the 1400
a month so I literally dropped the broom
I was like what's happening with them
and then again he said no no no trust me
trust me trust me and my mom's look at
her my mom's looking at me and my mom's
saying well I can I can rent this place
out the stage is about there's no
problem guys you don't have to do this
and Anna say no no no no I've learned
this I've learned that I've done this
all week she was buzzing she was just
you know she was really confident in
what she's just learned so again I trust
in my wife and again over a year later
that three bedroom property in
Hertfordshire with a nice big drive and
a nice Garden has been our best we're
into essay
she was all excited and yeah is there
lack of knowledge if you don't know you
don't know you don't know what you don't
know so that is what makes that
different and obviously we saw something
in you that way because the academy is
in an interview process yeah yeah you
know we we turn away a lot of people and
we there's some people like this example
say yeah I think you should yeah how did
you afford to do the academy because
obviously it's a big investment right
yeah in our case we does we mortgage our
house yeah we had the savings states in
the bank so the ideally was to get the
money to put in vrr to keep it recycling
yeah because we didn't know how to do it
that's why I went to the brmas because
we want to learn how people don't know
money money and recycle your money who's
thinking how these people that we was
thinking okay so we're gonna have to put
the 25 down then the money's sitting
there we're now so how do we move on to
the next one and we just we we couldn't
get we didn't understand we didn't
understand obviously we understand that
yeah so we did have the money sitting in
the bank so instead of Dubia we start to
invest in ourselves to learn how to do
it so that's it what they make such a
difference between I think it's as well
if you how much did you have from the
refinance in savings yeah we had a 100
one Gap so if you've got a hundred grand
if you're trying to invest a hundred
grand with no mentoring no knowledge no
support
it's you might be successful but trying
to invest 90 grand but with unlimited
mentor and all the support it's going to
go way further yeah someone with 90
grand that's got a mentor and loads of
trying loads of support power teams
listed as accounts and someone's got 100
Grand the United person can kick their
ass yeah so it makes sense and it's
obviously you know I think that the
crash courses are for everybody it's not
everybody
and then obviously further training it
depends on this younger person and
depends on your goals how long did it
take you before you realized that Anna's
decision was right how long was it when
you were just like you know what because
obviously at first it would have been a
bit you trust it you are yeah I did but
when did you realize
yes to be honest it was that first into
essay that we took off my mum we we we
followed your step-by-step plan you know
we staged it I give it a lick it pain we
got some new carpets so we made it look
lovely we done the guy it was not too
bad but we made it look really nice
staged it and then
the penny just dropped people just
started booking and just booking and
booking and they seem to love it we're
the holiday makers where people from
abroad we had contractors that wanted to
be close to London we were people
falling up and sending messages oh is
there fast trains into London and was
like yeah this fast link should be in
King's cross in 20 minutes oh have you
got a drive because I'm a contract and
I've got my van I'd like to reverse it
up to the house you know because I don't
want to leave it on the street oh I'm
coming to go to a wedding in half and
over a year they just haven't stopped
the people just keep on walking
yeah massive demand for it it's just
fantastic and then I think that's when
after the first couple of books I was
like wow this is actually working this
is bringing in money how much were you
charging on a nightly basis for these
bookings around 150 180. 150 180 and
what kind of occupancy rate have you had
on that first property over 95. yeah
it's honestly the number one so what now
turn it in there so if you're if you're
like basically 100
currency rate call it 160 pounds or not
on average that's brilliant about that
all close to about five grand yeah
they're thinking the first property we
became financially free with the first
property yeah that's the lack of
knowledge the property always being
there do you know but if they're not
lack of knowledge because when we talk
the property I was doing the manager I
we didn't have a channel manager they
didn't even pay for tournament I was
doing everything so it was cleaning we
were doing the garden we were doing
everything so from one Prophet I was
doing like two and a half for three
grand monthly yeah and how much were you
paying your mom for that problem we
would give another asking price we fell
a few in 100 pounds yeah a month so the
rent wasn't so she's happy and not only
is she getting the full Market rent 1400
but also you're keeping it pristine
condition yeah exactly so she's happy
you're happy yes and extra things like
if anything goes wrong we don't need to
call her or bother her go and insult
ourselves she's got peace of mind she's
got peace of mind how many rent to rents
do you have in total now now we got 80.
and now you don't need to worry about
any other work no no the business closed
down we close the business down in
December it took a couple of months
longer than we actually wanted but
because of the nature of the business it
was care you're dealing with human
beings and families and social workers
we didn't close it down until the 12th
of December I know that they land on the
12th of December so obviously we had
Christmas and the kids off on holiday in
it so we all said what January we're
going to start running we had the one
essays of from January because we were
full-time property and basically the
money from that one service combination
was basically similar to what I was
getting anyway for the last wow 10 years
it blew my mind yeah it blew my mind
honestly to do a bit of cleaning and
using the you know messages of that but
Samuel I don't know you obviously you
might not know about care so being care
and if there's anyone watching or
listening to be a carer to get any
decent money you've got to put hours in
you can't just do a nine to five it's
not like a shift work you have to put
the hours in to make it decent
decent money in you know so some months
I was doing two three hundred hours a
month ridiculous I was doing like 16
hour shifts night shifts going into day
shifts it was it was hard work and then
now my wife said trust me and here we
are six months later you know
I'm not doing half the stuff that I was
doing and we're getting basically the
same money it just blew my mind I just
couldn't understand now you can see why
everybody that they did yeah exactly
exactly those gold branches
exactly so from January we started
looking for more didn't we we started
making the phone calls we listened to
your advice you know you'll teach him we
had the script what to say to you know
to landlords or to estate agents we
started building relationships with the
stages and that area and stuff like them
and here we are now we have eight wow so
yeah and those are big deals
and we never left there says we we done
about three or four viewings last week
didn't we we're still looking for more
essays yeah we've got two that are in
the pipeline that are serious uh so he's
gonna come back to us with that but
basically there are and we're at the
stage now okay do we keep these or do we
do we package them and sell them you
know we haven't done deal selling before
but now because we've got their essays
we've got a choice now yeah we can sell
them or we can keep them deal sourcing
is super fast pound yeah because it's
cash in the bed right now yeah and then
rent to rent is pretty fast vrr is a bit
slow property development real slow with
property development although it's real
slow you can make a million pounds yes
yeah yes and as I said as you we talked
about it's nice to have a combination
you want to have a diversified toolbox I
don't think you'll be smart to be doing
Amazon Drop Shipping cryptocurrency
property all these different but I think
within property doing multiple having a
multi-faceted property business yeah
he's smart also they're bringing in
regulation I don't know if you've seen
the regulations that just brought in
about service accommodation what do you
think about that the fire yeah alarms
and stuff doors and yeah it's quite
often because I have someone I brought
to me she actually got one service
accommodation and she was complete panic
she was like how are we gonna do it I
think she's got one and she's completely
melted down because she doesn't have the
knowledge and I was like I'm just gonna
do the a blessing they're asking for
yeah and she's like but how I said we're
just gonna install fire dogs where it
needed to be installed whatever they
need half of them we take the boxes and
that's all I mean at the end of the day
it's short stay let's is it the way that
we run service accommodation and even
Airbnb it's a relatively new business
yeah and if you look at most property
strategies like hmos hmos are very very
regulated with Airbnb up until recently
you could literally just have a shed in
your garden and just say I'm gonna rip
the out
and then what happens if it burns down
and someone dies in it oh wow oops but
now because it's becoming more
mainstream more common more accepted I
think it's only natural and only
expected that the government are going
to do again I think we'll continue to
get more regulated it might be that in
five years time you need planning
permission and I think makes make uh hey
all the sun shines yeah and you know you
guys full-time property many great money
you're also doing the slow pan stuff as
well yeah now looking to potentially do
a bit of deal selling what's the
strongest reason why what was it about
you Anna that made you the crash course
when you came with your mother-in-law
and you were like I'm all in I mean look
where did that drive and that fire come
from I think it's quite a hard one
because I always been a very hard worker
all my life so it's like gonna go for
something and you gotta go in full I
think it have the opportunity the
environment just help me pushing myself
I celebrate the process because I've
been in so many other designed business
before but the environment helped me to
just go so much faster being in property
we feel the academy things and the
people with the mentors just pushing us
and just telling us which direction to
go and what to do just make it so much
faster and it's true I mean just being
around people that are on the same page
as you that that want to go in the same
direction whichever whichever part of in
property they're going down but just
have that same mindset and it really is
you you go to these courses you go to
the dinners you do all this stuff and
everyone is just on the same page
everyone's buzzing everyone's excited
about the future everyone's putting in
the hard work and you can't help but be
swept up in there you can't help I come
away from a dinner or something just
positive it just lesbians it's fantastic
it's the environment it's amazing yeah
and when you sit at home by yourself
trying to do it by yourself it's hard
it's it's hard because you know family
of no one you're not learning okay
sitting there and also the regulation
now of the fire that came and you just
Panic yeah you just don't know what to
do what's now your small profit to be
consumed by uh all the the procedures
they have to do it so yes definitely the
environment yeah and what would you say
has been the biggest learning point over
the last sort of six 12 months which
you'd want to share with people
listening but me personally it's been
the learning it's it's it's changing my
mind in the way I think like I said I
worked in game for so many years and to
beautify that for one property that
wasn't hidden ass which is took control
of to basically get the same money
within months while I had salt away for
years it blew my mind like I said and it
Formed there obviously I started doing
the course and it's just learning it's
getting the information if you don't
like the information you don't know and
you just can't go anywhere you can't go
forward because you just walked around
you know what you're going to do yeah
and that's how I feel but now learning
and getting the information and
basically learning from people like
yourself who's been there done that book
a t-shirt now if someone's telling me
I've done this this is the way to do it
I'm gonna listen
I don't want to listen and I'm gonna
take what they're saying and I've got to
put it into action and we're going to be
successful so for me it's the learning
it is it's changing the way I think I
want it to soak up every bit of
knowledge so I can take that and do it
myself with my wife so that that's why
I'm taking it yeah I think getting out
of your comfort zone yeah yeah because
obviously we had a business which it was
extremely comfortable we know everything
in aspect of the business without doing
much the money was company we didn't
have to do marketing research nothing
was a direct debit between to the
business so I can actually know what's
gonna happen the next year
because the money was a stand direct
payment so being business is just
getting me out of this comfortable Zone
where like every day I have to challenge
myself of learning something new get
myself there out there talking and
learning and that is difficult about
this challenge yeah yeah nice so easy no
no it's not easy are you confident your
confidence does grow yeah you get your
first essay so to speak then your
confidence grows so you now now you're
talking to landlords you talk through
stages because you know what you're
talking about now you know I've got one
so now I want two I want three eggs you
know you have your confidence grows
confidence grows from knowledge yeah
when you don't know what you're doing of
course you're going to be unconfident
when you know the scripts and you've got
yeah exactly and that that's what
happened to us isn't it and I can't even
say slowly but surely because it was
pretty quick to be fair it's it's been
like you know just over a year and
really we didn't really get the ball
roll into January we had the one but
obviously closing down the business so
from January onwards we've just it's
been non-stop isn't it and then
obviously now we've just had the summer
season which has been fantastic it's
yeah it's it's been really good it's
been amazing we're really happy well I'm
really really pleased for you and you
got I couldn't wish it for a more
amazing power couple than you guys and I
look forward to seeing your continued
developments and keep on spreading light
and positivity massive thanks for coming
on the show thank you thank you so much
thank you
[Music]